si les lèvres autres en contact avec le
doigt c'est qu'on est mou sinon sinon je
vous le dis sachez lost une mauvaise
nouvelle vous n'êtes pas écrase le nez
la colle pour tout le monde alors ya là
pour qui ça colle pas et qui permet de
regarder ça colle pas on commence un
symbole
un touch profil sur michel s'est pas
pousser la crainte il écrase sourit il
est donné il faut pas écraser le d
isabelle morini-bosc sa touche pas
merci
[Applaudissements]
ah oui ça touche je vois et nohra oui ça
touche pas sa touche sa touche
je leur en serai à touches à ta connerie
et touche
ça cartonne sur internet
comme quoi ils peuvent nous faire faire
n'importe où au style une veillée